da sind so kleine köpfchen gerät sowieso
bald wieder aufgesetzt bekommen bei
einem neuen video natürlich geht es gut
und ich hoffe natürlich die gibt es auch
gut
er wollte ich weiß nicht ob er das video
gesehen habe wir haben irgendwann
vorüber in spanien waren schon mal
spanisch in spanien ja so was hattest du
jetzt mit euro ist tut sich das
irgendwann ach so also wir waren im
august in spanien und haben das
spanische süßigkeiten probiert und wir
haben hier um die ecke relativ solle
china laden da gibt's chinesische
süßigkeiten alles rund um das land china
und ich war wirklich noch nie in diesem
laden drin weil ich hab auch mal rein
und gestern haben uns gedacht er kommen
wir gehen immer ein bisschen shoppen
kaufen wie chinesische süßigkeiten man
muss auch dazu sagen ich glaube auf
youtube gibt es sehr viel diese asia
kalenders allerdings habe ich kein video
gefunden wo es nur chinesische sitz kann
jetzt und ich glaube dass hier sicher
dass die chinesische süßigkeiten als er
für 20 euro eingekauft haben hier oder
sieht irgendwie gar nicht gesund aus das
zeug chips sind auch dabei und auch und
auch getränke alter kommt euch dieses
getränk mal an sieht aus wie spülmittel
da kommt man hier steht jetzt auf
französisch heißt oder ob das konnte ich
aus china
das hier kommt aber auf jeden fall aus
china gibts auch chinesische chip wäre
auf jeden fall alles aus diesem chinas
tor und ja ich würde sagen wir probieren
das einfach mal hier macht es einfach so
wird schon alles hier ein ausschnitt die
chips und tina nacheinander
die leute dazu soll ich anfangen mit den
kassen ja gern hello kitty john barry
also sieht aus wie nutella zugang nur
mit anderer mit anderen dingen also
diese sticks sind einfach ein teller to
go sticks das finde ich falsch gemacht
dass man sich fragt wie kuchen
also ich würde sagen 87
ich bin jetzt auch nicht so schlecht
aber 52 mir dieses französische getragen
aber aus dem chinesischen gesetz dass
irgendwas ist irgendwas mit metall somit
wahrscheinlich airlines oder gar nicht
nach milch und joghurt natürlich riecht
das nach ich mich schon
[Musik]
ich finde das schmeckt nach sowie aktive
schmeckt und wie actimel sondern mich
diese anderen länger auch so klein und
ich finde es eine verlängern
da ist ja sogar kunden yakult kennen sie
ja kult also ich bin das schmeckt schon
ähnlich wie actimel mit kohlensäure und
nicht so mächtig echt lecker so das
sieht halt krass eklig aus finde ich
aber es schmeckt also ich kann das so
trinken so einfach nebenbei okay wir
kommen zum nächsten
ach so ja stimmen ablehne 77 gegeben
dann gebe ich diesmal nach dubai ist ihr
volk sind jetzt wieder unterwegs
aber das sind andere als ich kann hier
auch was deutschen aber das sind auf
jeden fall chinesische kann man sehen an
dem aufdruck und die sind von der marke
magee genauso wie das hier guck mal ich
glaube das ist so eine bekannte
chinesische süßigkeiten mache sie sehen
auch ganz anders aus als die deutschen
ich finde gar nicht gut also ich gebe
mir 322 punkte
also ich kann man rechtlich
weiterempfehlen ich habe vor das
schmeckt nach pappe wir haben hier
wieder ein chinesisches getränk das hat
sich cato leute ich weiß ja aber das in
der kamera sieht aber das schwimmen so
kleine stücke rum dass sie gar nicht
lecker aus du probierst als erstes
nämlich dass das reicht auch das nicht
genauso wie in dem geschäft gerechnet
dass er überhaupt wer eines zu trinken
mathematik ist das auch noch irgendwas
mit kokosnuss war das nicht so kleine
klitschen gelehrt wie so klein ich bin
die quallen einfach nur wow das sind
gummibärchen das so eklig irgendwie also
diese matte geht man hätte ich mir das
ganze einmal probiert aber das ding ist
ich glaube die haben da so gummibärchen
reingemacht so diese strawberry teile
quasi gibt in seiner grund herum
[Musik]
ich finde es einfach so eklig wie kamera
macht man das verstehe ich auch nicht
aber so also es ist jetzt auch nicht so
ich jetzt doch immerhin es ist also ich
gebe mir gebundene 15 punkte
hier haben wir die heißt das ich finde
das sieht ein bisschen aus dem fiat so
auf den ersten blick aber so leute das
riecht auch für mich ein bisschen klüger
an das einstellungs seid ja eigentlich
wünsche eigentlich ganz gut so es gibt
sieben punkte gegen programmieren wir
machen jetzt noch weiter mit den chips
und es liegt wohl täglich lassen sie
ganz fertig aus dem zimmer gehen
überhaupt nicht lecker um eine sehr gute
mannschaft bis zum 9
lecker lecker
nicht alles kann sie ist also hier
gewinnen 99 punkte das sind die gleichen
mit schokolade also heute hier haben
hier nun schneller bin ich mal gespannt
wie die schokolade schmeckt ganz gut ein
bisschen muss sie gar im internet besser
mit will ergo hinzu es gibt sehr sehr
auf den tankstellen kpmg das auch gut
das kann man auch hier als orden steht
für nutzen zum sommer hier probieren und
wir haben zum schluss dass man mir am
anfang gesagt habe dass sie richtig
eklig aus israel kommt das aus der
schweiz
hier haben wir diese zentren für ganz
viele chinesische schrift man weiß nach
bahrain erklärt wick 2 3
ich möchte mich gut ich denke die jetzt
auch wieder nummer eins ist finde ich
täglich weil durch magische das ist das
süß dabei ist ja süß verschwiegen des
offi kuchen ja was für mich zählt so
sieht also ich bedeutet 1 überzeugt ich
hab ne 77 punkte profil was hattest du
von einem machtspiel das also okay was
findest du von einsamen am besten also
ich fand die chips am besten und das
getränk
also leute das ist gutes getränk die
chips und auch die chinesen können
anscheinend gut chips machen das waren
ein paar chinesische produkte ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen ihr könnt ihr in
die kommentare schreiben
ihr habt schaut auf jeden fall weil
marie auf instagram vorbei und bei mir
sowieso und wir sehen uns dann morgen
wieder wahrscheinlich da gibt es nämlich
ein neues video hat rein